one of
the leaders in the tournament well
second place right now second place
right now as a matter of fact he started
off the day well but
had a difficult game to start out with
we're with world number two fabian
caruana fabi the game
i i know you know the game against ikaru
queen e5
uh that could have just been
brilliancy and kept you going but you
did bounce back
win a game and then a very tough
struggle against kasparov yeah the first
game was disappointing of course because
i i felt throughout the game that i was
better
and
and at some point i was sure i was
winning and i also had more time than
him for most of the game
um
it was a
the fourth round right yes no you could
keep talking about it and um
yeah i mean he tricked me with this
amazing resource a4 i mean i assume it
doesn't save the game but at least
it at least uh
makes things really difficult in time
pressure i had like two minutes and
suddenly i before i knew it i had no
time at all and uh
and it was very difficult to figure it
out um
and okay yeah this game was a nice
bounce back of course i
really didn't have any right to win this
game because the second the second game
you can saw
against maxime i mean i was worse out of
the opening
um
eventually i like at some point i
started out playing and i got a slight
advantage in the endgame and
uh man it should have been a draw but he
went wrong i think he
he mis-evaluated the bishop ending it's
actually extremely dangerous for black
uh while if he keeps works on then
rook's on then then it should be a draw
and the last game against gary i mean i
i felt like i was completely winning but
um
but i messed it up in time trouble again
50 on the day
still within range of the leaders
that disappointment from the first round
though it did it carry over or
you feel like okay that was a solid
result bouncing back
no i mean i i didn't think too much of
it and i completely forgot about it
after
after i won the next game uh i felt like
that was sort of a wash because
yeah i could have won the first game but
uh but i could have also
been pressured in the second game and
not had any chances to win
uh but overall i did i think miss a few
chances
more than i gained today what's your
feeling about seeing gary play so well
bounce back with two great wins today
and then a tough fight against him do
you feel like
you're playing against the lion with the
will to not lose for sure
well he always has the will um i mean
he's he's an amazing competitor even
though he's uh nowhere near
his peak uh he's still he still tries
extremely hard and he's still very
strong um
it was of course sad to see in some
tournaments that he he collapsed this
year but
but it's good that he's playing well
here all right well thanks for joining
us and good luck tomorrow thank you